okay so in this video I want to talk
about enzyme kinetics and the
michaelis-menten model the
michaelis-menten model
okay so enzyme kinetics really just
describes it's a study of the rates of
reactions right so if we want to know
how fast an enzyme works we want to find
out what that's dependent on as it turns
out we want to know let's say for
instance we want to know how the
substrate concentration impacts the the
reaction velocity so what we're going to
do here is we're going to have we're
going to plot reaction velocity the
y-axis and then have substrate
concentration on the x-axis right and
I'm just going to write substrate
concentration as like this okay the s of
course standing for substrate now the
other thing there's these things called
enzyme assays or assays I don't know
exactly how to pronounce that but the
point is they're a lab technique okay
they're a lab technique and I don't
really want to write this all down I
don't to waste too much time but
essentially what they do is they allow
you to measure either the appearance of
a product or the disappearance of a
substrate in either case they allow you
to measure the rate of a reaction right
which or the velocity of the reaction
which is what we're trying to think
about here okay so let's sit for for a
particular reaction for instance there's
this this example chymotrypsin is a
protease which is an enzyme that breaks
up proteins if we graph its velocity
over over the substrate concentration
what we get is a graph that kind of
looks like this
actually that's a little bit off let me
do that again
that's a little bit cleaner okay cool so
we've got here is what do we notice here
well what happens as we increase
substrate concentration well as we
increase the substrate concentration
we're having an increase in velocity
but out of the reaction so what that
means right at least for the short
period of time that increasing the
substrate concentration increases the
reaction velocity so the enzymes right
the enzyme in this case chymotrypsin
which actually spell out for you right
here kymo trypsin okay so the velocity
out at which the enzyme works increases
as you increase the substrate
concentration right but at a certain
point we sort of level off here right so
there's a plateau okay so now beyond a
certain point no matter how much extra
substrate you add the enzyme cannot work
any faster right so that's its maximum
velocity right so if we think about that
right here something like that right the
velocity at which you know you can't go
any faster that's going to be considered
the maximum velocity and that has a
particular name v-max okay so why is it
this happens up here why do I is there's
this plateau effect um the reason why is
because because you can imagine that if
there are a particular number of enzymes
right if there's a small number of
substrates they can just not do them
really quickly and as you add more the
enzymes have more to work with so they
can work faster but at a certain point
the enzymes let's the baby they're
working as hard as they can as fast as
they can right and they can only keep up
with the substrate concentration to a
certain point once you once you
basically once all the enzymes are taken
and they're all working at their maximum
capacity you can't you can't you know
increase their maximum capacity so
they're going to work at a certain
maximum velocity and no matter how much
more substrate you add there's not going
to the enzymes are not going to work
faster so what we sort of say here is
that this plateau right this plateau I
just wanted I do that this plateau is
due to what we call enzyme saturation
right which is just the idea that
there's there's too much substrate for
the enzyme to handle the enzyme or
enzymes to handle okay so it can only
work so fast that's the maximum velocity
and if you want to know a little bit of
a few more details that you'll notice
here there's a sort of direct
relationship there's like a linear
relationship for like this certain point
here right so that that here there
that's first-order kinetics right and
what does that have to do with that's
the whole idea that if we have if we
have a recall I mentioned in the last
video I mentioned the rate laws being
something like this if a rate law isn't
it has a substrate in first order then
doubling the concentration will double
the rate law tripling the concentration
of the substrate will triple the rate
screen have the rate law triple the rate
so there's a direct relationship here so
for the that's that the direct
relationship is usually just you know
visualized and represented by this by a
line at a certain point we here no
matter how much we increase the
substrate concentration nothing happens
that's going to be zeroth order kinetics
right so this is this here is
first-order right if we have a rate law
for second order or it's not a second
order excuse me zeroth order
have zeroth-order then anything raised
to the zero power is one right so a
substrate concentration if you have if
we double the substrate concentration
nothing happens to the rate right the
rate doesn't change because if matter
what you put in here it's going to end
up equaling one right so this is the
whole idea that no matter how much
substrate you add or increase or
decrease whatever it is up at a certain
point it's not going to you know
increase the the v-max or the maximum
velocity because the enzyme is saturated
it's working literally as hard as it can
okay so I mentioned this here v-max and
then I'm sort of leading this all into
the michaelis-menten model this is idea
of km and I'll elaborate on what exactly
km is in just a second but oftentimes
people talk about km is equal to v-max
over two and that isn't entirely correct
so the km have the right the way we find
it and I'll elaborate on its definition
in a moment when we think about km we
think about v-max over two right half
the v-max so if we think about v-max up
here and you know zero being down here
somewhere in the middle right that's
actually a little bit too high maybe
maybe down here whatever anyway at v-max
over two half the v-max if we go over km
is not equal to v-max over two what it
is equal to it is the substrate
concentration at v-max over two so here
at the max over two right half the v-max
we have our particular substrate
concentration so there that substrate
concentration oops that substrate
concentration at v-max over two is equal
to the km that's the km is equal to and
I'll go over more details in just a
moment okay so all of this here this is
a hyperbolic equation or a hyperbolic
graph okay so I want to note that here
this is a hyperbolic graph okay so um
why is it a hyperbolic well Michaelis
and Menten they sort of dealt with that
figured it out and they understood it to
a certain degree and they kind of
explained it a little bit so their model
me scroll down a little bit actually
I'll write it in here so Michaelis and
Menten thought felt their way through
like this they thought let's say we have
an enzyme denoted by E and we have a
substrate right so we add a substrate to
an enzyme what can happen is that enzyme
and substrate come together and form an
enzyme substrate complex ok so because
in order for the enzyme to catalyze a
reaction it needs to come to it is the
substrate needs to bind it at the active
site and they did you know interact so
that when that when they actually
interact that's going to be called the
enzyme substrate complex and what's
supposed to happen is the enzyme and
substrate right will create a product
denoted by P and the enzyme will hop off
unchanged right back to what it
originally was ok or or this enzyme and
substrate complex if it doesn't go to
completion and create a product they can
just associate and go right back to
being an enzyme and a substrate the
reactants that you begin with now each
one of these reactions has has a K or
give me a rate constant K associated
with it let's call this one k1 let's
call this one k2 and let's call this K
negative one because it's going
backwards ok now what the km is actually
equal to the km d km is equal to K K
negative 1 plus k2 over k1 now so what
are we talking about here what is this
this is kind of confusing right so let's
let's go over this briefly so now
essentially what you'll notice is that K
negative 1 and K 2 both are rate
constants for reactions that involve the
dissociation of the enzyme substrate
complex with a breaking up the enzyme
substrate complex so here we have the
enzyme substrate complex k2 describes it
breaking up into product and enzyme
whereas k negative 1 also describes the
breaking up the enzyme substrate complex
back to en
s so we can think about this top value
sort of representing this idea of the
enzyme-substrate complex you know
breaking apart okay the enzyme substrate
complex breaking apart and then on the
flip side right okay negative 1 or Sigma
K over 1k 1 right here
it describes the formation of the enzyme
substrate complex so that that value
sort of describes the enzyme substrate
complex either coming together or
staying together ok so if we think about
that then what we can kind of understand
then is that km essentially is a measure
of affinity and Association ok it is a
measure of dissociation or affinity of
an enzyme for a substrate or an enzyme
for an enzyme in a substrate now why is
that well if we think about this top
number right sort of being you know
describing the enzyme substrate complex
breaking apart and this bottom number
being the enzyme substrate complex
staying together well then we can
imagine then that if km is a bigger
number right if km is a bigger number
and then what we have if we have a high
km what that means is if this probably
this large number right it Ord assuming
that this top number it's probably the
large number dominating this bottom
number so if there's a large km that
means this top number is overpowering
this bottom number which means that the
enzyme substrate complex is breaking
apart more than its staying together ok
now what that means then then that means
that there is a so excuse me if if the
end if the oh my goodness let me say
that all over again
if there's a large km this top number
right is overpowering this bottom number
which essentially means that the enzyme
substrate complex is breaking apart more
than is staying together
which means right which you can sort of
deduce or think about as being you know
you can imagine that as a sing sort of
the same thing as that's a low affinity
for the substrate the enzyme has a low
affinity for the substrate low affinity
for the substrate so a high km means the
enzyme substrate complex don't have a
high affinity for each other they're
breaking apart more than they're staying
together so that means there's a low
affinity for a substrate right so the
opposite is true then so if we have a
low km if we have a low km then that
means this top number is not dominating
like this bottom number this bottom
number is which is sort of implying that
the enzyme substrate complex is staying
together more then it's breaking apart
forgive my my handwriting here so what
that means if that is that if you have a
low km that means you have the enzyme
has a high affinity for the substrate
right because if they're staying
together that if the enzyme in the
substrate are staying together they have
a high affinity for each other they're
very attracted to each other whereas if
there's a high km they have a low
affinity age for each other because
they're breaking apart more often okay
so so essentially what's going on here
is that this is the idea behind km okay
and this all plays into the idea this km
and v-max are very very important
because they are involved in the
equation that Michaelis and Menten
figured out as far as the the hyper
which is called the as far as this graph
goes which is called the hyperbolic
equation which I'll write down here so
the hyperbolic equation is V right if
you want to find V for a particular
reaction that's going to equal the v-max
times the substrate concentration over
the km plus the substrate concentration
so so this is the hyperbolic equation
right why is this useful at all okay and
why should we care about it at all
well it's useful because if we know the
v-max of a particular reaction and we
know the km then we can find the
velocity at any given substrate
concentration that we want okay so I'm
going to write that here useful because
if we know v-max and km for a particular
enzyme we can calculate the velocity at
any substrate concentration okay so I
just wanted to introduce the
michaelis-menten model here along with
these enzyme kinetics as far as this
graph goes in the next video I'll talk
about more little bit more details as
far as the michaelis-menten model goes
and later I'll talk about the
lineweaver-burk plot